hello and to welcome to this video
playing shine offer playing the London
system this is a pretty interesting
sideline Bishop defies playing it
quickly which could mean that he has
some idea about this line or it could
mean that he just plays yeah without
thinking all that much but no I can't
before looks weird that a strange way of
playing it is a strange way of playing
here black is definitely in excellent
shape so even if five becomes very
interesting here but I think castling is
good white doesn't have a decent move
anyway so let's see him I can play
Bishop a3 and just be annoying he 5 is
also very interesting yeah let's do that
I mean if he takes it I have rupee eight
or just Bishop takes c3 and the White
King is feeling very very unsafe in the
center yeah that is possible but I can
take on f4 and yeah this is already
answer a hard one to believe okay so I
can also play a move like Queen to e7 or
Queen to b6 I have like it's been anyway
the thing is what what is the best line
I give a tick III
yeah I mean it's got night seafoam b6
and trapping the rook here but he has
rook c6 then yeah which is not great
either yeah it's a tough one I mean
black will have a huge advantage in
pretty much regardless yeah well how is
that even possible
okay I take check g3 Queen checks and I
have Queen before at the end so
basically like him then he will go g3
king it to us probably even more of a
catastrophe here I'm threatening the
rook and I'm threatening Queen two
before winning the c5 rook that should
be the end of the game the Bishop g4
line is pretty interesting actually it's
not I mean not some kind of miracle
weapon to refute them the London but it
is not not too bad
white White's best move is probably
Bishop e2 or 90 of three is something
conservative and that is not really
putting black into danger f3 is the more
ambitious choice the problem is that
this is kind of semi useful coating the
Bishop to d7 while f3 is just not a good
move
it doesn't help and in particular if I
go c5 Queen b6 quickly here the dark
squares will be weak and you already now
have to be quite cautious with white
some people have even tried g4 it's a
bit of a shocker
like house counterplay yeah it's quite
interesting c4 can be answered by the
direct c5 as you see this the engine top
choice I analyzed said some weeks back
and I thought that black is already very
comfortable because I mean any normal
transformation in the center now will be
rather favorable if you imagine white
place let's say what the engine suggests
Knight to c3 then we could get into
something like this where I mean it's
it's basically going to be in iqp
position where this is just looking
wrong yeah again black is not winning or
anything but it's pretty ok but he
played D takes d5 immediately and this
is already putting right into some risk
I think and after before it's already
terrible already I don't know he never
spent any time a 5v5 Bishop c5 white
position is a wreck already ok castling
is huge
e5 is even stronger hmm yeah it's it
doesn't really matter that much I mean
white cannot develop normally anymore
the pawn to f3 is just terrible and now
he 5 I'm not sure it's one of the top
choices takes and take take yeah here
many moves are good Queen e7 I consider
taking only three I wasn't sure I took
it and I expected of course Knight c4
and here I wasn't entirely certain what
to do because I can definitely play b6
and trapped the book but he has rook c6
and I was not totally sure about this
it might be just winning but these kind
of pawns they tend to be dangerous if
you take it for example this year I
wasn't in a blitz game not and didn't
have time to figure out if you can just
play like this for example probably you
can there's nothing those pawns are not
so dangerous yeah okay a 94 it's just
immediately losing this is hanging and
this is hanging as well so white is
losing a rook now
yeah I mean we know this kind of kind of
game people tend to mean if you really
are surprised in the opening and
obviously I was playing this quite
quickly and anyway thinking a little bit
can help you know if you play something
conservative you're at least not going
to be worse with white and the way it
went white was basically toast after
eight Moore's okay guys thanks for
watching